and she sometimes opens for me on the
road and she opens also for Bill burr
and Kevin Nealon and I'm your third
don't admit it right now the third
choice never hang out during the day you
know I want to go paddleboarding Kevin
Nealon goes paddleboarding with me he
did what he did and what does Bill burr
do with you bill we go to barbecue we
learned French we drive around the site
oh well that's why I'm third wrong you
don't do that stuff when do you ever see
me during the day now I don't know what
you look like
do you know why because you're sleeping
yeah okay because I have [ __ ] to do it's
so funny ah but being on the road with
you is the funniest so that's why I do
and so I mean to you you said you're why
I remember one time you're just looking
at me and you go ugliest tiniest head
[Laughter]
your head looks like a [ __ ] brown
peanut like I just want to eat it yeah
but her proportions are all picky really
she's 46 years of pounds but you really
need to eat something
listen guys I eat more than most people
yeah you do I do I know I go out to you
know type in tech tell people my rule my
rule okay this is really mean to a spec
well not as much now but when Jeremiah
Watkins also up somebody that opens for
me it really hates that I do this yes so
go ahead let me start with something
sweet Bobby's the most generous person
ever he takes everybody out to dinner he
treats everyone he's very sweet he
orders for the table very alpha okay but
then very alpha when you're broke and
you're on the road and you just want a
piece of beat so late at night in your
own hotel room that's not allowed
you can't take the leftovers Bob will
not allow it oh he made me shove a box
of pizza down a trash can that was
maybe smush it crush it in yeah while he
was yelling at me and J tell me why
because it's his food that he brought we
talked about this
oh no he does the same thing with me I'm
not allowed to everything love leftover
why did the best because I mean I'll
tell you why it's not a power thing it's
a power thing listen to me Gilbert right
now listen to me right now okay is if I
pay for the meal it's mine
it's an Indian gift no it's not even
Indian good how [ __ ] dare you take it
back he just forces you to throw it away
so when you start packing up my food and
you're gonna go hey I'm gonna take it to
my hotel room I say no because it's not
yours right price so it's like this it's
like if I buy you its shoes are a little
different shoes are different I've
bought in people should I bought your
shoes my shoes cuz we were in Chicago it
was on my birthday and I was really sad
and lonely because then he took me to
the mall and bought me some shoes really
I think you got them for him some shoes
I got Fahim Anwar some shoes right shoes
are a little different because what am I
gonna do with them I mean I hate their
sunrise right I mean I feel like if I
get you shoes I can take it back at any
time I don't you know I'm not Indian
giver
yeah what is Indian give I never forgot
Korean giver waking back which you give
to somebody
yeah but I have never taken back shoes
but I'm just saying theoretically and
philosophically you could I could all
right yeah so with the food you stays at
the table alright you know what this
[ __ ] does my man my beautiful
girlfriend she gets she goes I'm gonna
take me back from Korean barbecue okay
alright it's because I want to give it
to a homeless people on our way a car
for three months because he doesn't
allow me to get out the car
so stop stop right here separately yes
zooms past them Bobby you know Shh
okay I'm gonna say this a homeless
and doesn't want Korean barbeque back
but he can trade with someone for maybe
a cigarette that then can be traded for
a razor blade but then can be traded for
a cash for drug currency chris d'elia
one time I gave a homeless guy 20 bucks
and he kind of grabbed me cuz you know
what he's gonna do with that money I go
what he goes he's gonna buy crack why
did you do that Chris because yeah I
said cuz I don't have crack on me what'd
he give it a crack if I could give him
crack right then how first of all let me
say this how happy would the homeless
person be well whatever dream right yeah
whatever drug they want shaky yeah yeah
yeah they'd be like no but I have crack
you'd be like are you Jesus are they
agent as sorry
almost impressions aren't good
[Music]